perhaps even more interesting than
finding the inverse of a matrix is
trying to determine when an inverse of a
matrix doesn't exist or when a when it's
undefined and a matrix a square matrix
for for which there is no inverse of
which an inverse is undefined is called
a singular matrix so let's think about
what a singular matrix will look like
and that how that applies to
the different problems that we've
addressed using matrices so if i add the
i'll do a two by two because that's just
a simpler example but it carries over
into really any size square matrix so
let's take our 2 by 2 matrix and the
elements are a b
c
and d
what's the inverse of that matrix
well this hopefully is a bit of second
nature to you now it's 1 over the
determinant of a
1 over the determinant of a
times the adjoint of a and in this case
you just switch these two terms so you
have a d and an a and you make these two
terms negative so you have minus c and
minus b
so my question to you is
what will make this entire expression
undefined
well it doesn't matter what numbers i
have if i have if i have numbers here
that make a defined then i can obviously
swap over make them negative and it
won't change this part of the expression
but what would
create a problem
is if we
attempted to divide by zero here if the
determinant of
the matrix a were undefined so a inverse
a inverse
is undefined
if if and only if and and you know in
math they sometimes write it you know if
with two fs if
if and only if
the determinant of a
is equal to zero so another way to view
that is if a determinant of any matrix
is equal to zero then that matrix is a
singular matrix and it has no inverse or
the ma the inverse is undefined
so let's think about in in in the in
conceptual terms at least the two
problems that we've looked at what a
what a zero determinant means and see if
we can get a little bit of intuition for
why there is no inverse
so what is a zero term well in this case
what's the determinant of this two by
two well the determinant of a
is equal to what it's equal to a d
minus bc is equal to a d
minus bc
so this matrix is singular or it does
have it has no inverse if this
expression is equal to zero so let me
write that over here so
if a
d
is equal to bc
or we can just manipulate things and we
could say if a over
if a over b is equal to c over d right i
just divide both sides by b and divide
both sides by d so if the ratio of a to
b is the same as the ratio as c to d
then this will have no inverse or
another way we could write this
expression if
a over c if i divide both sides by c and
divide both sides by d
is equal to b over
d
so another way that this would be
singular is if
and it's actually the same way if this
is true then this is true these are the
same just a little bit of algebraic
manipulation
but if the ratio of a to c is equal to
the ratio of b to d and you can think
about why that's the same thing as the
ratio of a to b being the same thing as
the ratio of c to d anyway i don't want
to confuse you but let's think about how
that how that
translates into some of the problems
that we looked at
so let's say that we
we wanted to look at the problem
let's say that we had this matrix
representing the problem
the linear equation problem well
actually this could be either one so we
have a
b
c
d
times
x y
is equal to
i don't know
two two other numbers that we haven't
used yet e and f
so if if we if we have this matrix
equation representing the linear
equation problem then the linear
equation problem would be translate a
times x
a times x
plus b times y
is equal to e
and
c times x
plus
d times y
is equal to f
and we would want to see where these two
intersect that would be the solution the
vector solution to this equation
and so just just to get a visual
understanding of what these two lines
look like let's put it into kind of the
the slope y-intercept form so this would
become what
in this case y
is equal to what
y is equal to minus a over b minus
a
over b
x
plus e over b
right i'm just skipping some steps but
you subtract ax from both sides
and then divide both sides by b and you
get that
and then this equation if you put it in
the same form just solve for y
you get y
is equal to
what minus
c over d
minus c
over d
x
minus c over d x
plus
f over y
so what do you what what
let's think about this let me i should
probably change colors because it looks
too
let's think about these two equations
what these two equations would look like
if this holds right
and we said if this holds and then we
have no determinant and this becomes a
singular matrix and it has no inverse
and it's um and since it has no inverse
you can't solve this equation by
multiplying both sides by the inverse
because the inverse doesn't exist so
let's think about this if this is true
we have no determinant but what does
that mean
intuitively in terms of these equations
well if a over b is equal to c over d if
a over b is equal to c over d
these two lines will have the same slope
they'll have the same slope so if these
two expressions are different then what
what do we know about them
if two lines that have the same slope
and different y intercepts
they're parallel to each other and they
will never ever intersect so we could
let me draw that just so you get the
so if that's
you know so line
this top line
might look well they both have let's say
these are pi they don't have to be
positive numbers but this has a negative
i'll draw it as a negative slope
so that's the first line
and its y-intercept will be
its y-intercept will be e over b
e over b that's this line right here
and then the second line now let me do
another color
would look something i don't know if
it's going to be above or below that
line but it's going to be parallel
it looks something like this
it looks something like that and that
line's y-intercept so that's this line
that line's y-intercept is going to be
f
over y so if e over b and f over y
are different terms but these both lines
have the same equation they're going to
be parallel and they'll never intersect
so there actually would be no solution
if someone told you well you know just
the traditional way that you've done it
either through substitution or through
adding subtracting the linear equations
you wouldn't be able to find a solution
where these two intersect if a over b is
equal to c over d so one way to view the
singular matrix is that you have
parallel lines then you might say hey
sal but these two lines would intersect
if e over b equaled f over y if this and
this were the same then these would
actually be the identical lines and not
only would they intersect they would
intersect in an infinite number of
places but still you would have no
unique solution you would
you'd have no
one solution to this equation it would
be true at all values of x and y so you
can kind of view it when you apply the
matrices to this problem
the matrix is singular if the two lines
that are being represented are either
parallel
or
they are the exact same line they're
parallel and not intersecting at all or
they're the exact same line and they
intersect in an infinite uh
at an infinite number of points and so
it kind of makes sense that the a
inverse wasn't defined so let's think
about this in the context of the
of the linear combinations of vectors
that's not what i wanted to use to erase
it
so when we think of it when we think of
this problem in terms of linear
combination of vectors
we can think of it like this this is the
same thing as
the vector
a
c
times x
plus the vector
b
d
times y
is equal to the vector
e f
so let's think about it a little bit
we're saying is there some combination
of the vector ac and the vector bd that
equals the vector ef
but we just said that if we have no
if we have no
inverse here
we know that because the the the
determinant is zero and if the
determinant is zero then we know in this
situation that a over c
must equal
b over d so a over c is equal to b over
d so what does that tell us
well it essentially tells us that well
let me let me draw it
and maybe numbers would be more helpful
here but i think you'll get the
intuition
i'll just draw the first quadrant
i'll just assume both vectors are in the
first quadrant
let me draw
so
vector ac let's say that this is a let
me do it in a different color
so i'm going to draw the vector ac so if
this is a
and this is c
then the vector ac
looks something like that let me draw i
want to make this neat
the vector a c is like that
and then we have the arrow
and what would the vector b d look like
what is the vector bd look like
well the vector bd
well unless you know i could draw it
arbitrarily some place but we're
assuming that there's no there's no
derivative sorry there's no determinant
have i been saying derivative the whole
time i hope not well we're assuming that
there's no determinant to this to this
matrix so there's no determinant we know
that a over c
a over c is equal to b over d or another
way you could view it is that c over a
is equal to d over b but what that tells
you is that both of these vectors kind
of have the same slope so if they both
start at point zero
they're going to go in the same
direction they might have a different
magnitude but they're going to go in the
same direction so if this is
if this is point b
and this is point
d
vector bd is going to be here
you might just want to think if that's
not obvious to you think a little bit
about why these two vectors if this is
true are going to point in the same
direction
so that vector is going to
essentially
overlap is going to have the same
direction as this vector
but it's just going to have a different
magnitude
it might have the same magnitude so my
question to you is
vector ef we don't know where vector ef
is well let's say
let me just pick some arbitrary point
let's say that this is e and this is f
so this is vector ef up there i'm doing
a different color
vector ef let's say it's there
so my question to you is if these two
vectors are in the same direction maybe
of different magnitude is there any way
that you can add or subtract
combinations of these two vectors to get
to this vector
well no you can scale these vectors and
add them and all you're going to do is
kind of move along this line you can you
can get to any other vector that is a
multiple of of one of these vectors but
you can't get
because these are the exact same
direction you can't get to any vector
that's in a different direction so this
if this vector is in a different
direction there's no solution here if if
this vector was
if it just happened to be
if it just happened to be in the same
direction as this then there would be a
solution where you could you know just
just scale those actually there would be
there would be an infinite number of
solutions in terms of x and y
and then but if if the vector is
slightly different
in terms of its direction then there is
no solution there's no combination of
this line of this vector and this factor
that can add you up to this one and it's
something for you to think about a
little bit it might be obvious to you
but the other way to think about is when
you're trying to take sums of vectors
you know any any other vector in order
to move it in that direction you have to
have a little bit of one direction and a
little bit of another direction to get
to any other vector and if both of your
kind of ingredient vectors are the same
direction there's no way to get to a
different one anyway i'm probably just
being
circular in what i'm explaining but that
hopefully gives you a little bit of an
intuition
of well one you now know what a singular
matrix is you know
when
it's
when you can
when you cannot find its inverse
you you know that when
when the determinant is 0 you won't find
an inverse and hopefully and this is the
whole point of this video
you have an intuition of why that is
because if you're looking at the vector
problem there's no way that you can find
that you'll either that there's no
solution to finding a combination of the
vectors that get you to that vector or
they're an infinite number and the same
thing is true of finding the
intersection of two lines they're either
parallel or they're the same line if the
determinant is zero anyway i will see
you in the next video